I thought I you know mix things up a bit
come outside today um I I guess I'll
talk about the three circle fountain I'm
well you know I I want to make videos
but I'm trying to figure out what to
what to do it on I I've put everything
into the online courses so I feel like
I've shared so much but I'm I'm looking
for for a new stuff so you know always
if you ask me it really helps because
and is that interaction helps you know
there's less people I've been tuning
into my videos and so I'd love to
somehow get that back up but I don't
know how I'm gonna do that but so today
let's talk about the three circle
fountain if you follow me I talk a lot
about the four by four fountain right
and notice my right hand tucks around my
left ribs and then my left hand tucks
around my right ribs so right tucks
behind left tucks behind the right tucks
back and windmill left tucks and that's
a ends up being like a four circle
pattern so each point bins and you can
get to all line up nicely where say the
left the right foot is an in spin up
from the bottom left foot is an in spin
down from the top and you start having
these like the six in spin poi flower
awesome I like it it's a nice pattern so
this guy Matt well Keenan the Costa Rica
last year and he asked me all these good
questions he asked me whether there's
like the three circle variation and and
we messed with it and I realized you can
just drop out either the stuck behind
say instead of tucking my right behind
I'm just gonna come back up to the
windmill like this so the left tucks
behind the right doesn't left tucks
right doesn't so I take one of those out
what happens pretty quickly as I can
find the left PI that's an in spin there
and an in spin there and the sorry the
left way and the right point has an in
spin up from the bottom and down from
the top up from the bottom and done from
the top so if I space all those out I
end up with a 4 in spin pattern it's
been in spin spin spin spin spin spin
spin spin it's a nice rhythm to it it
feels a little weird li asymmetrical to
me still yet I'm really glad Matt asked
me that and I'm glad I did it because
it's kind of cool flow I could also take
out I could tuck the right and take out
the left and then I end it with the left
making in spins top and bottom and right
making in spins that decides you do it
either way and that's it so there's
always ways I mean I've done play for a
long time and I still somebody asked me
a question I realize there's still stuff
I've never done so if you just mess
around you can always find something new
and of course we like novelty so this
Nick reporting from outside at the buy
thin things as I said are pretty quiet
here unlikely anything very interesting
is gonna go on for a while but if you
see some if I make something you like
please do share it it helps motivate me
if people are tuning in and check out my
online poi courses if you haven't
because that's how I'm getting through
this pandemic and I hope you're some are
awesome alright you have awesome people
around you
or you have some way of staying snug and
cozy and happy
[Music]